Hello, everybody.
I'm Jordan.
Thank you so much
for inviting me here.
I'm excited to share
with you our Google Cloud
solution that we started looking
into almost a year ago today.
So to give you just a brief
history-- so I'll try and speed
through this as
quickly as I can--
I work for a company
called Rodeo FX that
was started in 2006.
The company in 2006
was basically matte
painting and compositing.
So you can think
Photoshop, a lot
of different layers
in Photoshop,
and then you can
think integrating it
into a live plate environment.
Pretty cool.
At this time, I was actually
working for Sony Pictures
at Image Works.
And although I'm a
software engineer,
I got a job working
the graveyard shift
on Polar Express.
I was a render wrangler.
So effectively, my job was
managing the render farm,
managing the storage, and making
sure it all worked correctly.
If you guys could have told
me 10 or 11 years later
I would be sitting up here
talking to you about render
farm, storage, and
making it work correctly,
I don't even know what to say.
So I'm quite surprised.
So then I moved from Sony Los
Angeles to lovely Montreal.
I moved from a company that was
massive with a massive pipeline
and a massive infrastructure
to a company that
was about yay size when I got
there, maybe about 30 people.
We all fit into a stairwell.
And effectively I was tasked
with the filling in the rest
of the pipeline, being
able to bring Rodeo
to a company that
would be much larger,
that could handle all
aspects of visual effects.
And as of today, we are growing.
We are actually 230 people.
We are stretched across three
different studios in Montreal,
Los Angeles, and Quebec city.
And as described, we actually
won our very first Emmy award
for Game of Thrones, which
we were really excited about.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.
And then on top of that, we
got a Visual Effects Award
for our work on "Birdman,"
which we were incredibly
excited about as well.
So we are definitely originally
a tiny little boutique studio,
but as you can see,
we are moving our way
up in the industry.
That said, one of the things
that was really important
was, especially a studio that
was maybe 15 to 30 people,
is we wanted to be nimble.
We wanted to sort of retain
the qualities that made
us successful in the beginning.
So this nimbleness,
the ability to be
flexible the ability
to be inventive,
we didn't want to be
constrained to any one thing.
We wanted to be able
to make all things work
and whatever the
solution could be,
we were going to go with the
one that was the most amazing
and the best at that
time in order to bring
about the most beautiful shot.
That's pretty cool.
So this is Rodeo FX today.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So that's really cool.
But my position is
to make sure that I'm
looking ahead in the future.
And so, I'm really
happy that we're
able to present a
reel like that today,
but of course, I need to
be constantly looking ahead
and trying to find the best
tools and the best workflow
to allow us to continue
to not only produce
these types of images, but also
to produce even better ones.
And of course, the focus for
us has always been the same--
produce the most beautiful
image that we can.
And we're never
satisfied until we do.
But beautiful shots take
a lot of time to render.
And unfortunately,
you can through CPUs,
you can throw storage, you
control everything at it,
but time is never your ally.
And as we wrapped up last
year around this time for Game
of Thrones, I
needed to look ahead
to figure out how I was
going to be able to support
a lot of different productions.
I needed to be able to come up
with my own emergency button.
And that was actually
what brings me
to my presentation
today-- the way
in which I ended up building--
or we ended up building,
excuse me, because
there's a ton of engineers
help me on to do this we ended
up building our Google Cloud
proof of concept solution.
So the first thing
was transparency.
Artists are very fickle.
They do not like change.
And they particularly
don't care if they're
rendering in the cloud or
rendering locally or rendering
on their machine.
They just don't care to know
what happens under the hood.
So whatever we did,
whatever solution we chose,
it had to be something that
was more or less hidden
from the artist and
hidden from production.
On top of that, scalable.
Obviously, we are
a small studio,
so the ability to be able to
scale, to be able to burst,
to be able to handle whatever
emergencies are coming up
at that time is super important.
Easy integration and management.
We have built out our
own pipeline-- I mean,
obviously, we have
our own pipeline--
and we've integrated
it enormously
with products like Shotgun
and with products like Cube.
And we really had no intention
of tossing that all away
and trying to adopt
something else in parallel
or trying to completely
reinvent the wheel.
We wanted to use what we had,
we just wanted it to just work.
Obviously, it
needed to be secure.
You can just take a
look at the Sony hack,
you could take a
look at Expendables.
It's a common theme
in our industry.
And it has to be
price-conscious.
We use our render farm seven
days a week, 24 hours a day.
So those needs need
to be able to fit
and not completely put
us out of business.
So the first thing
I did was I enlisted
one of our engineers, Alan, and
I called him a Cloud Pipeline
TD, and he seemed to be
cool with that title.
And so, he ended up sort
of helping me build out
this proof of concept.
The first idea that was the
not invented here strategy.
I went and took a look at a
lot of common turn-key options.
And unfortunately, nothing
really met our needs.
So we ended up going with the
build it yourself strategy.
And the same vein, we
started looking at all
the different options there.
And what became sort
of a common theme was,
Google ended up
coming out, checking
all of the boxes for us.
So once we had sort of decided
on where we were going to go,
now we needed to start
building our solution.
So, this is sort
of our prototype.
We started with a single machine
which just one NFS share.
And it could handle
a dozen slaves,
and we were super
happy about that.
But it failed.
As soon as we went
above about a dozen,
all of a sudden,
a frame that would
take maybe 20 minutes suddenly
was taking an hour and a half.
And we had angry artists.
So we needed to go
back and rethink.
So then we ended up
choosing GlusterFS.
And it was open source.
And so just to give you a
sense of how things grow,
September 22, 2014, we went
with a 9 terabyte usable stores.
We thought, that's amazing.
That will be more than enough.
And it wasn't enough.
We toppled that thing
really, really quickly.
I think at that time we
were working on Sunday night
football, the opening
for Sunday night football
and the Super Bowl, and
it was just killing us.
So we ended up by increasing
the storage space.
We went to 18 terabytes,
and again, to 30 terabytes.
As you can see, we just keep
needing more and more storage,
and we were using it.
Finally toppled out at 48.
And we could scale the storage.
And we were like, fantastic.
We've totally fixed it.
If I render locally at Rodeo,
if I render on the cloud,
we're getting equivalent
times, artists are happy,
and we have a little
bit more flexibility.
But the configuration on the
cloud was really not ideal.
So we needed to go back
and again, rethink that.
Initially, we were just using
a very kind of simple VM.
And what we would do is update
it and then push it out.
But ultimately, that also
became a really, really,
really hard thing to manage.
So we needed to sort of
go back and think, well,
what's more flexible,
what's more granular?
So we started using Salt. And
like I said, I'm providing you
with a solution.
I'm not revealing any
secret strategies here,
Rodeo doesn't work
with secret strategies.
We try and work with
whatever is available,
whatever is out there, we
think that's the easiest
way to get from A to B.
So we use Salt-- open source,
free, it's actually quite good.
So we've got our
Salt master, we've
got all of our Salt minions,
and the Salt minions then
ask the Salt master for
their configuration,
and we can manage
these configurations
in one central spot.
And guess what-- it works and
it actually works pretty well.
As soon as an
instance starts up,
it makes sure that it
has everything it needs.
As soon as it starts up, it
has everything it needs-- boom,
Cube, which is our
render tool, immediately
starts up and starts accepting
jobs and starts rendering.
And then as soon as we did that,
our Salt master accidentally
went down and we
realized, we probably
could use more than
one to have redundancy.
So we ended up going with
a multi-master setup,
and that ended up working
really well as well.
The other issue
that we had was just
IO from Montreal to
the Google Cloud.
Montreal's a great city, but
its connectivity to Google
is a little shaky at best.
And of course, the first
thing we used was rsync.
And rsync is not awesome.
And it was topping out at
300 megabits per second,
so it just it simply
wasn't meeting our needs.
So then we found a project
by the guys who smash atoms
together, an open source
project called FDT,
so made by the CERN lab.
And suddenly we were
able to get speeds
that were huge-- one gigabit.
So huge, in fact, that I started
taking down Rodeo FX anytime
I started pushing data up.
So we ended up
solving that problem.
Everything worked great.
We completely have
our solution now.
We've solved the
disk storage, we've
solved the ability to
move data back and forth.
So everything's fantastic.
So effectively, we've sort of
built our own little pipeline.
And the idea is, when anybody,
especially with a company
like Rodeo FX,
where typically we
are looking to render locally
and live at Rodeo as much as we
can, but when it
gets too out of hand,
we need to be able to
press the emergency button.
And that's the whole point of
our solution into Google Cloud.
So Carrie Underwood, the Super
Bowl-- boom, emergency button.
Summons the Gluster
storage pool,
suddenly we have our storage.
The artists then tick,
yeah, use the Google Cloud.
They don't care.
Then, cleverly enough,
it goes back to Shotgun.
Shotgun all of a
sudden goes, great,
do you want to
render this scene?
Well, let me go and
take a look using
the Shotgun toolkit--
amazing, amazing, awesome API.
It says great, you
need all of this stuff.
Bam, thank you, Shotgun.
And then we use the CERN lab
FDT to upload everything.
The VMs are booted,
the VMs are configured,
and all of a sudden we start
rendering Arnold, Houdini,
whatever you want.
And everybody is happy.
And then once the
rendering is done,
we use the same
product from CERN
to pull it back down to Rodeo.
Not terribly complicated.
And like I said, just a
lot of engineering, time,
and a lot of failures to be
able to get to a solution that
ultimately ends up working.
And so we're quite
happy and quite
pleased with what we've got.
And effectively, we were able to
transform our emergency button
into a Google emergency
button and then turn it off,
because we only need it
when we actually need it.
But it's always sort
of there, ever-present.
And it's exactly
the type of stuff
that when we need to
call upon it again,
we are all ready to go.
That is my presentation
and thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]